So let's say that we're going to play repeated trading games,
and if you're a very agreeable,
then you're going to bargain harder on my behalf,
then you're going to bargain on your own behalf.
Whereas if you're very disagreeable,
you're going to do the reverse.
You're going to think,
I mean this trading game for me and you are going to take care of your own
interests where an agreeable person is going to say no,
no,
at best this is at worst,
this has to be 50 50 but I'd like to help you every way I can.
Okay,
now the credit,
okay,
so you Kinda,
you kinda understand that.
Now the advantage to being agreeable then is that you're good in teams and
you're very much likely to give other people credit that bad.
The downside of being agreeable is that you're not very good at putting forward
your own interests.
And so one of the things that predicts salary across time,
for example,
is agreeableness.
And it predicts it negatively.
And so it's part of the reason why women get paid less than men.
And this is something for the women in the class to really listen to because
you,
how you get paid across time depends on a very large number of things,
right?
It depends on your skills and your abilities and your position and your social
network and all of that,
but the other thing it depends on is whether or not you actually go ask for
money or maybe that you don't even ask because actually you don't ask for money.
You tell people that you need to be paid more or something they don't like will
happen and I don't mean as a threat.
I mean that you have to be willing when you're negotiating to have an
alternative,
you go talk to your boss who isn't going to give you money because everyone
wants money,
right?
It's a competitive game.
You're going to have to be,
you're going to have to go there and say,
look,
here's what I do.
Here's why it's useful.
Here's why you have to give me more money and this is by opportunities.
If you don't,
and then you're not taking your boss's money anyways because it's very seldom,
very frequently the case that he's working for a whopping big company,
but he needs an excuse to give you money because everyone's asking for money all
the time.
And so you have to put your case forward powerfully and disagreeable.
Now,
you don't want to do it to disagree and bleed because then he's going to think
that you're a son of a bin.
Maybe he's not going to give you anything,
and maybe you'll get fired for being mouthy and all of that.
And that certainly happens to people who are too disagreeable.
You got to get the balance right,
but it's definitely the case.
And the other thing that happens to women that's also worth noting,
and this is probably because they're higher negative emotion,
is they tend to underestimate their own utility in business settings,
right?
Because if you're trying to evaluate what you're like and you're more tilted
towards negative emotion than the things that you do that are wrong are going to
stand out more,
more on the foreground and the things that you do that are right.
So if you go into a negotiation and you're uncertain already because you have
self doubts and then you're agreeable in the negotiation,
what's going to happen is that you're not going to win as often.
And winning in in a business setting or in a career development setting means
more opportunity for promotion and more revenue generated.
Now the downside of that,
of course,
is as you climb the business hierarchies that you also have to take on more
responsibility.
And that responsibility is sometimes unpleasant as well,
especially to people who are agreeable because you're not necessarily liked if
you're in a position of authority and agreeable people really like to be liked.
It's their primary motive motivator because they're concerned about the
maintenance,
I would say,
of of,
of,
of intimate positive relationships.
But that also makes them conflict avoidant.
Okay.
So now you guys can think about this,
but,
but I'll,
I'll tell you why.
I think the personality differences between men and women exist now,
these are speculative hypotheses,
but they're reasonably well documented by,
by the relevant literature.
So let's,
let's think about it.
The first thing we might think about is what's the difference between men and
women?
Well,
how do they differ?
the first thing we might observe is that if you look at personality differences
between p pre pubescent boys and girls,
they're not very large.
Boys and girls don't differ in terms of their,
their trait neuroticism,
for example.
What happens is that when puberty kicks in,
women's trait neuroticism rises and it stays higher than men for the rest of
their life.
And this is why you see this reflected in the different kinds of psychopathology
that be set,
the two sexist.
So men are overrepresented in alcoholism,
drug abuse,
antisocial personality,
and a host of learning disorders as well as add attention deficit disorder.
And women are overrepresented in depression and anxiety primarily.
That seems to be tightly associated with higher levels of trait neuroticism
because maybe it's if you're at the 95th percentile or higher,
let's say in trait neuroticism,
there isn't much different than difference between that and being somewhat prone
to depression and anxiety.
And because the curves overlap,
you know,
th th th the curves aren't identical.
The normal distributions are identical for men and women.
You tilt the one to the,
to the right,
to the women's curve,
to the right towards higher levels of neuroticism.
You go out,
you look for the person in 20 who has the highest levels of negative emotion,
it's much more likely to be female than male.
Okay,
so let's see if we can figure out why.
So we're going to tell you some things,
basic differences between men and women.
And you can tell me what you think about it if you are,
if you agree or disagree.
Okay.
First size differential emerges between men and women at puberty,
right?
Because boys and girls are roughly the same size and roughly the same strength.
But men get bigger at puberty when the testosterone kicks in.
And more importantly,
not only do they get taller and heavier,
but their upper body strength is much higher.
And that's a real issue for for combat because human beings punch.
There's other animals that do that.
Kangaroos do that two ways.
So we're not the,
we're not the only people that punch,
but we have clubs on the ends of our arms.
So That's interesting.
So okay,
so there's a bar,
there's a body size difference that's important to strength differential,
that's important.
Next thing I think.
So let's assume that the reason that women are higher in sensitivity to negative
emotion is because the world is actually more dangerous to women.
I think that women's nervous systems are not adapted to women.
I think women's nervous systems are adapted to the mother infant dyad.
And because you are not the same creature when you have an infant,
not at all,
you're way more vulnerable.
And it's partly because you have to express their vulnerability of the infant
and you also have to care for it.
Right?
So you think about an infant,
especially under nine months.
So let's say,
how are you going to be wired up if you're going to optimally care for an infant
under nine months?
And I'm saying under nine months,
because women generally do the bulk of childcare for infants who are under nine
months old.
And part of the reason for that,
there's a whole host of reasons,
but part of the reasons for that obviously is that they breastfeed.
But imagine what you need to be wired up biologically in order to care for an
infant.
First of all,
they're very demanding,
right?
Because they're completely helpless and they're demanding 24 hours a day and
it's quite,
uh,
emotional load.
And an infant under nine months is never wrong,
right?
What you do to an infant under nine months is when they're in distress,
you always respond.
You never tell the infant,
get your act together and stop whining,
right?
Which you can do,
say to an end,
to a child that's 18 months old,
you can start having that sort of conversation,
but under nine months it's like nothing is the infant's fault.
It's surrounded in an extraordinarily threatening world.
And you have to be responsive to what it needs regardless of what you want.
And you have to be very sensitive to the threats that emerged in the
environment.
And so I think the price that women pay for that ability to have an intimate
relationship with infants in the very earliest stages of development is that
their nervous systems are actually wired so that they can perform that role
optimally.
And the disadvantage to that is that having a temperament like that doesn't work
that well when you're dealing with adult men,
especially when you're dealing with them and in a business environment because
it's not the same thing.
Not at all.
It's a competitive environment.
So,
okay,
so agreeable people are compassionate and polite.
What are disagreeable people like?
They're tough minded.
They're blunt,
they're competitive,
and they won't do a damn thing they don't want to do.
So it isn't exactly that they're aggressive,
although they will push you the hell out of their way if you're in the way.
They're not.
They're not like volatile like you are.
If you're high in neuroticism,
it isn't defensive aggression.
It's more like predatory aggression.
It's dominance behavior.
And so for someone who's high,
who's high,
highly disagreeable,
they look at the world as a place in which they can compete and win.
And I'll tell you a story,
I have a friend,
I gave him my personality test,
the Big Five aspects scale that Colin de Young developed tongue in my lab.
And uh,
I knew he is a disagreeable guy and by interacting with them,
I mean he's even rude to people sort of spontaneously on the street.
I actually liked them quite a bit.
He's very,
very funny.
He's also very conscientious so you can trust them,
but it's disagreeable as hell.
And uh,
so I gave him this task because I thought it would be funny and he came out as
the most disagreeable person in 10,000 so reasonably reasonable in compassion,
both 30th percentile but like 0.001 in politeness.
So he's extraordinarily blunt and he'll just say absolutely anything,
no matter how horrible it is.
And he was often brought into corporations to sort of clean them up.
So if a corporation was tilting and not doing well,
they bring him in to find out how the useless people were in fire them.
And I talked to him about that because I've had the miss opportunity to have to
not have graduate students in my lab,
for example,
that weren't performing well.
And I'd find it very,
very difficult to,
you know,
dress someone down and certainly difficult to fire them.
I just hate it because I'm actually quite an agreeable person,
much to my chagrin.
And I asked him about that and I said,
well,
what do you do?
You have to fire people all the time.
How do you handle out?
He says,
handle it.
I enjoy it.
And I thought,
wow,
that's so interesting that someone would have that response.
I said,
well,
what do you mean you enjoy it?
He said,
look,
I go into these companies and I analyze the performance of groups of people,
right?
And there's in those groups,
there are people who are really striving,
really trying hard and working themselves really hard and being productive.
And then there's these people that are just doing nothing.
They're completely in the way.
They don't carry their weight at all.
They take advantage every chance they get.
And they're always whining about why they can't work.
It's like I find out who they are and call them into my office and I tell them
exactly what they've been doing.
It's like hit the road buddy.
You've had your,
you've had your run of it.
And I thought,
Oh yeah,
okay,
fair enough.
You know?
Well,
I can tell you,
you know,
I've had situations in my lab where I had underperforming graduate students and
one of the things that was really awful about that was that it was really hard
on the high performing graduate students,
you know,
because they felt that even being in the same category as the people who weren't
working hard and pulling their weight devalued what they were doing.
You know?
And that's exactly right.
And so this is also why there's,
there is a conscientiousness trait and it agreeableness trait because
conscientious people judge you on your accomplishments,
right?
They don't give a damn about your feelings,
not a bit.
It's like,
are you doing the work or not?
Whereas agreeable people think,
well,
you know,
your mother is sick and you know you've,
you've got a bunch of family problems and we all have to take care of each other
and it's no wonder that you're having a rough time.
And like you can't say that one of those attitudes is correct and the other
isn't correct.
You can't say that.
There wouldn't be those two dimensions if there wasn't something correct about
both of them.
But you can certainly point out that often they conflict,
you know,
and so the demand for,
for inclusiveness and unity and care and the demand for high level performance
in a hierarchical structure,
they're very different orientations in the world.
And so it's complicated for people who are agreeable and conscientious.
And actually I think often that large corporations and large,
large institutions of any sort run on the unheralded labor of people who are
high in agreeableness and high in conscientiousness and they're
disproportionately women in my experience in large institutions,
has been that if you want to hire someone to exploit appropriately,
not appropriately,
if you wanted to hire someone to exploit productively,
you higher middle aged women who are hyper conscientious and who are agreeable
because they'll do everything.
They won't take credit for it and they won't complain.